this looks your dark no hi my name is
gray something good no no you know your
life is different now I started making
some videos that I have my thoughts and
feelings about all the reality TV that I
was watching and then I fell off from
making them cuz I got bored with some of
the shows I was watching stupid but I've
been watching the 90 day fiancé
franchise like crazy lately and I
thought I'd make a quick video because I
have some thoughts and feelings and
opinions and if anyone is as obsessed
with 90 day fiancé the entire franchise
as I am maybe we can commiserate or
debate about what we think is going on
so for those that don't know 90 day
fiancé is a reality franchise now on TLC
people from the United States that find
love in other countries and then they
bring their significant others to the
United States and apply for a k1 visa
which means that they have 90 days to
get married and it's so fascinating as a
reality show I love it now they've
expanded it they do before the 90 days
after the 90 days 90 day fiancé the
other way where Americans go to other
countries and it's just all around a
real sad delight it's a very tragic
thrill that disgusting to say I think
that's all reality television is at its
core anyway and I love it so the two
shows that are on right now are 90-day
fiance before the 90 days and 90 day
fiancé
the other way let's just dive into
thoughts my apologies for people that
don't watch these TV shows this won't be
an interesting video so just like with
those TV shows don't watch or watch try
and figure out from context clues go
back watch these shows and see what does
see what lines up for you okay but
stretch because this is gonna be a
marathon that's turn 90 day fiancé
before the 90 days also I'm probably not
gonna explain as much context about all
this because I'm assuming the people
that watch this show will watch this
video I'm sorry I'll have other videos
going up all throughout the next few
weeks that might appeal to the wide
variety of people that aren't glued to
reality television in an effort to avoid
all the other responsibilities in their
life like I am can't spell productivity
without why okay Angela Michael I love
them
so much Angela is born red raised and
made for reality TV he is a sassy
Southern woman that I would never flip
in a million years you couldn't pay me
enough to [ __ ] with Angela they're
maniacs and they love to love and love
to fight they are constantly fighting
she is constantly walking away I feel
like you could just make a montage of
her telling him to get away and her
leaving and going and chain smoking a
cigarette and drinking some sort of like
fruity looking cocktail in a random bar
that she finds oh she's incredible now
they're talking about having a child
she's 53 I think so this last episode
they went to a medical facility in
Nigeria to check her ovaries to see if
she's still in the eggs left to see if
she even had the possibility of having a
child cuz ain't no way she's gonna let
her man sleep with another [ __ ] just so
he can have a child in the Bible
somewhere I'm sure so they go to this
clinic and the woman puts the ultrasound
they write in her cooter and they're all
around in there and I was shocked that
her ovaries were just all so
chain-smoking
but she has one egg left and when they
show that screen I just kept thinking it
looks familiar I think I stole that
photo for me that's my last brain cell
watching reality television very cool
she gets very excited about the egg and
then realizes that it's very much not
gonna be a possibility because she's
full-on in menopause for like seven
months so now she's gonna ask her
daughter if her daughter will give her
an egg and I can't wait to find out what
happened next week's episode is gearing
up to be pretty explosive and I'm out of
here okay then you have Tim and Jennifer
as I like to call them alas nice
commercial they have the most beautiful
eyelashes individually and collectively
that I've ever seen it kind of looks
like a poor man's Adam Levine he
obviously has way better hygiene than I
do so I'm not making fun of him I'm just
drawing comparisons and she looks like a
goddamn supermodel he's a little bit
pouty a little bit wimpy it she's into
like machismo dudes it seems like and
they go to a zoo he's scared of all the
animals she wants to do this like swing
ride he doesn't
do it they have an explosive argument
about him being a [ __ ] and at one point
she asked him like what do you enjoy
doing and I genuinely wanted to hear his
answer but he never gave it because he
was so mad because he seems like the
kind of person that like likes shopping
for sheets like he likes like folding
things he genuinely finds pleasure and
like cleaning out his ears I don't know
they seem very mismatched but we'll see
how it goes
thoughts okay Rebecca and Zia doors I
like to refer to her the woman that has
Britney Spears esque makeup she wears
that smudgy black eye the same way
Britney Spears does which I have a
conspiracy theory is tattooed like
Britney the her makeup is the same in
every single Instagram post that has to
be tattooed anyway what is happening
there basically that's stuff like $200
so he could go buy a ring for her but
you didn't tell her it's a whole goddamn
mess and also she's a private
investigator in real life so she was
doing background checks on him and
supposedly he doesn't have a job or has
never had a job on his background check
but he tells her that he is an audience
coordinator for a TV show like he gets
people in the audience to watch the TV
show and technically by making this
video talking about these TV shows he
and I currently have the same job don't
come from me Rebecca also she's still
married as she hasn't told him yet so
there's a lot but I do like that they
almost have the same haircut thoughts
now and every couple thoughts Benjamin
and a kini oh my god
you know it seems like the happiest and
strongest relationship on this entire
show is a keaney with a margarita I envy
that they go to a zoo also lots of zoo
dates on this episode and then they go
and eat dinner and she has one margarita
and she is
shit-faced I wish I was that cheap of a
date she takes a sip of a margarita and
says that she can speak to Jesus I wanna
I'm gonna start using that but I do feel
really sad because she's got a son back
home and he seems like a really decent
dude and he's like trying to figure it
all out if she comes to United States
steer clear of Applebee's thought Caesar
I'm looking at me here cuz I wrote notes
cuz that's how much of a dork I am about
the
Ceaser's lovely if it's just like the
salad you get into it with like the best
of intentions for like ultimately you're
just so unsatisfied I feel so bad for
Caesar but I'm hoping that his exposure
on the show might lead to some potential
[ __ ] cats I think you should get a cat
I think he would be a lot less lonely
and a lot more like engaged in his life
if he had like a little animal like a
cat to take care of he seems like a cat
person
thoughts Avery and Omar the young couple
like 19 year old said just got married
they're gonna go live in Syria together
I think because all of that's good table
is Avery's mom her mom is obviously
concerned about all this but it's truly
helping them get handled Avery and her
mom should be a team on The Amazing Race
I think they would really dominate with
the way that they were able to figure
out how to get married before she had to
get on her flight also he had his first
kiss on his wedding night he said it was
weird that bodes well for the future of
their sexual relationship thoughts Darcy
and Tom Oh No
Darcy's emotions are like her cleavage
it's in your face it's all over the
place
kudos to her I don't have the confidence
to wear anything like what she wears on
this show nor do I have the confidence
just like get changed on the side of the
street or do I have the confidence to go
on a show like this you know I watched
mary-kate and Ashley Olsen growing up
and I like wish that my younger brother
was maybe my identical twin because it
seemed like such a cool universe that
you could have with an identical twin
and then I watch Darcy and Stacy I think
it's her identical twin and I think I'm
good thoughts okay this is long-winded I
know but it's just exciting 90-day
fiance the other way here are some
quicker thoughts about this Tiffany I'm
Ronald are in South Africa right now
with her son Daniel one she's got the
greatest eye makeup consistently like
this is just child's play compared to
how she does her wig liner
very very jealous to her son is like the
sweetest little boy in the universe and
has such a giant grasp on like the world
but still in such an innocent way that I
just want him to be protected at all
costs three
don't really have much else to say about
their situation I hope for the best
thoughts falling Carini who okay Paul
and Karina have been in this 90-day
fiance world for a long time we all know
this they've recently had a child
together and every time I see Paul like
hold the baby or play with the baby I
get so nervous I feel like it shouldn't
be happening and this is coming from
someone that actually holds a baby like
a wet watermelon I can feel the camera
man behind the camera being like maybe
give it to crane just let Craney put it
keep it on the bed I also god bless
Carini she is a patient patient angel
Paul is when he's not slamming himself
in a chicken coop what he's upset or
running off into the woods he's
consistently berating her with questions
about if she's talking to other people
and if she still wants to get a divorce
so I is it is a tough one thoughts Laura
and elegant Laura is like in her 40s
she's getting married to a lledon where
is he from
oh no I looking up where he's from I
just found out spoilers wait this just
came out like 24 hours ago oh I can't
get into that here let's stay pure with
what we're talking about this video they
get married then this three-day ceremony
she convinces her son Liam who is I
guess about to enter college become and
finally part of it he obviously has his
reservations with alledon he doesn't
come to the first two nights of the
marriage ceremony which is three nights
in total and I love when alledon asks
Laura like why he doesn't come the
second night that Laura finally drops
the facade it just isn't flat oh boy he
has diarrhea oh my goodness just relax
man I want to send it to every person
that I have to cancel plans with has
diarrhea my goodness just relax man also
the last day of their marriage ceremony
like the big ceremony he is wearing this
Airy over-the-top wedding dress that she
didn't choose Atlit and apparently chose
for her and her soundbite of her in the
dress alledon thought this
look best on me so I just went with it
I'm a princess oh that's literally me
every time I go to like a fitting for
any sort of project and I'm too scared
to tell the stylist that I don't like
what they've put me in I'm a princess
oh I love it but then I just saw
spoilers about their whole situation I'm
not gonna tell you guys anything google
it if you want to but that's where I'm
at on that docks Jenni and Sammi oh wow
wow wow Jenni is like a 60 year old
woman anything from Palm Springs she's
gone over to India to be with Sammy who
she just found out has been married for
two years this is crazy the producers on
this season must be like oh oh oh oh oh
there might be like actual legal
repercussions for him she is not happy
she might be Jenny from the block prison
block because he might be going to jail
that's not a fun job I like Jenny very
much because she wails in a wide variety
of ways she looks like she sells like
wind chimes and wishes but sue meets
family and like the current wife's
family like broke into their apartment
and like confronted them about it like
this is full on Jerry Springer Shh right
now that's happening I also don't think
Jenny should wear too much about having
to like come back to the states and
restart her life I feel like she can
just move to Arizona and sell crystals
but damn I can't wait to see what
happens next
thoughts okay speaking of thoughts those
are all of my thoughts for these most
recent episodes of 90 day fiancé
before the 90 days a 90 day fiancé the
other way let me know if you guys watch
these and every now and then I want to
sprinkle in these very basic vids about
my thoughts and stuff again always let
me comment down below on what shows
you're watching and what I should get
into because one of my favorite
activities and like really strong skill
sets is finding shows to be used as a
form of procrastination and don't forget
to subscribe to this YouTube channel I
make videos I have a bunch in the works
oh you're gonna have a lot of more
content this month and you did last
month
that I don't know I'm a princess